less than two months from the release of
Avengers endgame we've still had no Hulk
sightings until the movie arrives in
theaters there's no way to know for sure
but for now here's a look at some of the
most likely reasons you haven't seen
Hulk in THE AVENGERS and game trailers
if the body count of Avengers endgame is
anything like what we saw in Avengers
infinity war then there's good reason to
assume the Hulk might not survive the
latest Avengers adventure in fact you
could argue that he has less chance of
surviving endgame than most we haven't
heard a lot about whether Mark Ruffalo
plans to keep playing the character
after this movie but we're pretty sure
Marvel won't be pursuing any solo Hulk
films anytime soon
additionally endgame marks the end of
the Hulk trilogy that Ruffalo discussed
with MCU boss Kevin Feige that began
with Thor Ragnarok so if there's a time
for the Hulk to take a final bow now
seems pretty appropriate if directors
Joe and Anthony Russo were to kill the
whole doing it early in the fight might
accomplish the same thing Hulk's beating
at the hands of Thanos did an infinity
war having Thanos defeat the Avengers
toughest muscle man in the first few
minutes of the film let audiences know
what kind of threat the heroes were
facing the stakes are likely to be
raised an end game and it may be that
the filmmakers decided the only thing
more effective than having Thanos ko the
Hulk in the first few minutes would be
to have Thanos take Hulk out permanently
if that's the case there might not
actually be much end game footage that
wouldn't spoil the heroes death hence
his absence from the trailers but if
we're being totally honest that doesn't
seem too likely compared with some of
the other possible reasons we've come up
with while green is the color most often
associated with the Hulk over the years
we've seen that green and gamma rays
don't always go hand-in-hand
the Hulk was gray in his 1st 1962 comic
book appearance and in the late 80s that
version of the Hulk meant his successful
return in 2008 the same year Marvel
Studios released the first two MCU films
Iron Man and Incredible Hulk marvel
comics introduced the world to the Red
Hulk a more villainous Hulk with bright
red skin so while it ain't easy being
green it may be even harder for the Hulk
to stay green it's possible that the
reason Marvel
studios has held back footage of the big
guy from the Avengers and GameTrailers
is that they plan to premiere one of
these non green Hulk's an endgame and
don't want to spoil the reveal of course
images snap to the forthcoming batch of
endgame action figures have already
revealed a green colored Hulk so let's
put this particular theory down as
similarly unlikely in terms of the
Hulk's appearance Disney was a little
mean to us when they released the
Avengers infinity war trailers shots in
the trailer clearly showed the Hulk
alongside Captain America Bucky the
Falcon and other heroes charging Thanos
Army in the Battle of Wakanda that of
course never actually happened chirp
Bruce Banner got to take a pretty
awesome joy ride in the Hulkbuster armor
but there wasn't much genuine Hulk
smashing and Avengers infinity war it
may be that the Hulk isn't in the end
game trailers because the Russos may be
trying to manage fan expectations who
knows how much Hulk will get by keeping
them out of the trailers Marvel Studios
may be ensuring that this question
remains as unanswered as possible so
that if he shows up at all we'll all
stand up and Cheer our faces off sort of
like this
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the most beloved moments of
2012's Avengers film was this classic
line from Bruce Banner amazing
it was a huge crowd-pleasing moment and
it officially brought the team together
after two hours of bickering while the
green guy hadn't been in the movie much
before that moment after that classic
line he stole the show there was this
moment and Hulk smash and this moment
and of course the best moment of quite
possibly any movie ever made by an a god
you dull creature and I will not be
bullied by and part of what made all
those moments so successful was the
relative lack of Hulk and the rest of
the movie chances are good the Russos
are building up to a new version of the
I'm always angry line maybe they plan to
redeem the Hulk's absence and thrashing
an infinity war by giving the green guy
in the same kind of memorable moment he
enjoyed in Avengers in the meantime
maybe they're hoping the Hulk's absence
from the marketing will make our hearts
grow fonder and our cheers that much
louder of course there's one more
possible reason we may not have seen the
Hulk and it's all the fresh Prince's
fault not too long ago Disney released
footage of Will Smith as Aladdin's
blue-skinned genie you really don't know
who I am
genie wishes Land none of that ring it
above the online responses were less
than ideal so good Marvel Studios a
subsidiary of Disney beholding the big
green Hulk back because they're still
feeling burned about going blue I feel
like a idiot could Marvel really truly
be worried about their special effects
in the biggest movie they've ever
released suddenly not looking up the
snuff I'm kidding rush Susan now if
there's one thing we know for sure by
now it's that Marvel Studios knows
exactly when to Hulk out and how keeping
the Hulk hidden can actually make the
biggest impact
[Music]
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
Avengers end gamer coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you